The hard work that I saw my
dad put into Chinesefood
makes me feel really proud.
Proud that I was lucky enough
to learn from a master.
I want peopleto value it
the same way that I do.
So what is the value of Chinese food?
Is it the taste?
Is it thehard work and the training?
Or is it the dish's history and
the nostalgia it makes us feel?
Tome, it is all of those things.
But the value of Chinese food is
often compared to fast food,
quickand cheap.
Although we've spent years
developing skills to cook faster,
Chinese food isn't fastfood.
It requires skills,
mastery of ingredients
and nostalgia.
Cooking represents all the hard
work and memories that we had,
learning the art,
mastering the skills
and understanding the
historyof Chinese food.
So the next time you visit
a Chinese restaurant,
just remember.
It's not just a
plate of fried rice.
It's so much more than that.